[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome to the lobby gam spots
weekly hang out every Tuesday at 2 p.m.
Pacific live live on gamespot.com except
this week uh we're in transition at the
moment gentlemen we're in a transitional
period isn't that right Eric Tay yeah
we're getting uh we're hoping to maybe
next week go live promises but that's
kind of the Hope um Josh and Dan are
kind of working on that I'll help them a
little bit but yeah we're in transition
yeah we got a big old Studio next door
that's being built it's actually not
getting put together for like 3 weeks uh
so we've uh we still have to do it in
this room and we're going to try again
next week uh to be live but yeah we're
shopping the show at the moment if you
didn't if you missed the last week's
show we we're shopping the lobby we're
changing up some stuff we're adding some
stuff and uh yeah it's a fun exciting
time you wouldn't know that Peter bar
because you were at CES all last week
that's not true I paid attention to
social media and you were [__] hyped
all the new plans I mean it sounds like
we're basically ready to clean slate
start a new and and you know what just
do something awesome that isn't what
people would expect or what we would
normally do yeah I think we got safe on
the lobby for a while where it was kind
of like it became cuz it's kind of it
became such an exhaustively big
production that like changing stuff it's
like a big ship man it's hard to turn it
you know so we kind of we we we had our
segments and we got like all you guys in
as experts to like talk about stuff we
didn't really like listen to a lot of
what people kind of wanted or I don't
think we did we're doing like the best
version of those conversations either
well let's be honest too we had
blueprints from the past that we trying
to sort of iterate upon and come up with
something that was similar but fresh but
in that same way we were also a new team
that was kind of trying to establish
itself in many ways and I think now
we've kind of got that foothold so now
is probably the right time to actually
make our Mark yeah and do something cool
and and moving floor is a real good you
know kind of opportunity to like force
your hand in doing it as well H yeah so
by the start of February we'll have a
whole new show uh but before we get into
what we're going to talk about this week
we got a bunch to talk about I want to
hear what you think about the HCC Vive
you've done all that stuff it's CES
again last week we're going to talk
about all the games coming in q1 this
year just to sort of give everyone a bit
of a plan of what's happening between
now and March so they can budget uh
we're going to talk about all the rest
of the Game of the Year awards that were
given out by our various uh other gaming
websites our competitors chew it out
friends competitors friends and
competitors uh and we've also got a
weird segment with Steve Gainer and
myself playing Counter-Strike and
talking about gone home uh which I'll
get to a little bit later H but first of
all uh there's a couple of we said we're
going to listen to your feedback we did
a lot of that last week and did a lot of
more commenting in the uh video Pages uh
and and and on Twitter and whatnot but I
just want to get down to a couple of
comments that we saw on the uh
rebuilding the lobby video and
specifically these three which kind of I
think were General uh kind of
representing what people wanted out of
out of the show going forward God I hate
going for going forward uh kaby or kabs
I don't know says one thing I really
like was the old Set uh it felt like a
gaming cave and was really well lit and
presented uh that said I think what you
said is true it felt too scripted and
that showed in the way you guys talked
with one another and the audience uh it
felt canned and less personal so I think
that's kind of like the crooks of what
we're trying to fix it's like we are
going back into that room we're not
going to do it in this podcast situation
forever and ever and ever but we do want
to make it a bit more like
conversational right T yeah I mean um
one of the things we're thinking about
is maybe like you said maybe we bring
these mics in we don't know yet that's a
that's a test kind of thing but um for
the people that were worried the couch
is coming back there will be some form
of a couch um that's I think sort of
decided but uh it's going to be better
uh I think we all kind of have something
a goal in mind kind of this this fresh
goal and uh we're going to try to make
the best that we can uh another one came
in drum J said this will be a great
opportunity to interview all kinds of
people involved in video games such as
developers artists musicians programmers
Engineers speedrunners live streamers
event promoters the list goes on this
was said by a lot of people actually and
that kind of like that's an interesting
one because uh for us like in video
production and probably for you guys on
editorial as well interviews forever
just never like there's like this vocal
minority of people who really like them
um but then sometimes you can like get
them to work like I think that you I did
The Witcher stuff that felt like it
worked it was like that was something
that people were actually interested in
um and this week's we do actually have a
developer we have Steve gner in like
based on a lot of the feedback we
immediately he was in town so we said
okay [__] it let's try and do something
interesting but like traditionally that
is something that's kind of hard to sell
right like interviews for a long time
were were really badly done so people
got a bad taste in their mouth I think
the big problem with interviews um is
that you know so often it's part of the
team's marketing push right they're like
we want our devs to talk to you and
you're like that sounds good and you get
there and they're like so they can't
talk about XYZ we'd love it if you would
ask them about this and you know for a
lot of editors uh pretty much every site
they kind of fall into that puddle and
they get wet with all the like marketing
BS but there are always topics to
discuss because these are actual people
and I think if we can get people outside
of the marke S of calendar here just to
talk about who they are rather than DLC
what mechanics their games have any kind
of that [__] I think any interview
with a human who is a part of this
industry can be interesting you just
have to figure out you know what are
they open to talk about why do I want
them in here it can't just be about
details for their game yeah and that
kind of is the problem isn't that that
most of the time they're available to us
is when they are literally doing that so
we have to kind of be more clever about
who we pick we kind have to pick yeah
the right people and actually it can be
hard sometimes because you also some of
the time you know who they are with
Steve like it's like okay he does idle
thumbs I know he's like good at talking
about stuff right sometimes it's just
like lead developer for some game and
the gamees really interesting but you
don't know if they're going to be
interesting true not everyone is good at
at being interviewed yeah so but yeah
that's definitely something we're
working on and we have it in this week's
show so let us know what you think and
then the last one uh before we get into
this week's show jarace great name uh I
think that online play with the
community will be awesome same as sweep
Stakes random prizes and mystery boxes
but instead for a chance to play with
the cast live online that' be pretty
cool H yeah so we are going to do that
Community show we were we're talking
about exactly what it is I've been
talking to another thing that people
said was we're not going to if we do it
on Friday we're going to do it before
UPF with giant bomb's community in mind
as well H so we're not like
cannibalizing uh CBS video game streams
um but yeah we're going to do that but
that won't be on here that'll be this is
like our discussion show we're going to
get guys feedback and talk about games
but then whatever the online play thing
is uh that's going to be kind of a it'll
be under the the umbrella of the lobby
but like a different thing so we're
still working itday still shopping it
all right gentlemen you want to talk
about video games still yeah it's here I
want to talk to you Peter Brown about
the consumer El Electronics
Show first thing that happens every year
it's like January comes along okay it's
going to be nice and quiet for games but
then suddenly all of CET and some of the
techy people on Gamespot end up going to
Vegas to see weird Contraptions uh how
was this year's show before we get I
really want to talk to you about the HTC
VI specifically because I thought your
your preview last week was very very
interesting but how was CES this year it
kind of felt like it wasn't super
interesting it wasn't super interesting
and that's a trend that's sort of um
been gaining momentum in the past few
years uh it's hard to know why I think
maybe the the the broader Innovations in
gaming you know we've sort of
established those uh a few years back so
now we're seeing are these sort of new
augmentations to gaming right and VR was
one of them that was really exciting for
the past few years but this year so much
of the hardware development that made
new experiences possible has plateaued
so then what we're getting are new
experiences but even those new
experiences aren't really delivering
something that's terribly exciting so
for me specifically going to CES this
year felt like a let down yeah because
nothing left me feeling like wow I can't
wait to tell everybody about that I was
VR stuff even the VR stuff I was
basically just doing my job and I love
VR you know and there are some
experiences that that really speak to me
there weren't I didn't the only one
there that that really moved me in a way
where it's like man this is special was
something I did back in March so I can't
attribute that to a success of CES which
one was that um so this is I forget the
name of it but it's essentially a HTC
Vive demo where you have a palette with
a bunch of different colors you can
choose from a bunch of different brushes
and you can paint in 3D space and move
around this box and and again like paint
in 3D space there was a demo in uh by
one of the Disney artists who did uh the
Beast from Beauty and the Beast and so
imagine you just have a brush and you're
just like drawing curves and you can
like change your perspective on that
curve and it just hangs in midair and
you can add to it and you can add
effects to it cool it's it's the sort of
thing you just lose yourself in because
it feels like magic it's not trying to
take a first-person shooter or anything
we know about in relation to video games
and put that into VR it's something that
is like okay VR is different what would
we like to do with this technology like
forget everything we know let's start
from scratch and this is a really good
example of that so let's I guess one of
the cool things about this year CES was
that yourself and Justin got to
experience Oculus and the HTC 5 like
within minutes of each other yeah at the
same appointment it was with Nvidia and
it was literally leave from one go right
to the other so I'm really interested CU
most of the time there's like months
apart where that's the case so I'm very
interested to hear uh what you think or
like develop on what you said last week
which was the HTC you're actually way
more excited for that than the Ulus now
I'm more excited for it in terms of
where I think it's going to take VR
faster um because it is very much a
premium product right it's going to be
more expensive than the Oculus I cannot
imagine how how expensive it's going to
be 750 yeah that that's my guess just
because of like all the extra stuff you
need well well you get all the
accessories right I don't know if you
get all the accessories you don't with
with the rift from Oculus you just get
the headset right you don't get the the
hand tracking stuff you get the Xbox One
controller too I mean not that that's a
big deal that's well yeah I mean that's
not a VR accessory right that's just
like a yeah that's just a regular thing
yeah so but for for the the Vive you
have these two controllers that are kind
of similar to auses but not um without
getting into too much detail and then
you have these sensors that detect where
you are in space um but the one feature
that the Vive has that you can't find on
the rift is this this Magic Eye sort of
camera on the front right and what that
does is um when you walk up to a wall or
you're near an object uh this can detect
how far away you are and it's sort of
creates like a ghostly image within
whatever experience you're doing doesn't
like flip to the camera it creates like
a ghostly image of what's near you so
you know like oh crap I'm about to walk
into a wall is it literally that wall
but just like transparent or something
like it's like a transparent like Misty
Blue that appears and you're like okay
like if I get too close it gets bigger
if I back up it fades away it's like the
virtual reality ver version of uh the
when you're reversing in a car and it's
beeping it's like that thing where it's
no yeah yeah if you're close to it and
that does help why does it sounds like
the type of thing that would be anti-
immersive because it's pulling you back
into the real world but well I mean
let's be honest right like if you know
we're going to be doing VR and moving in
free space we have to be cognizant of
the world around us and if you were in a
game and you constantly had a wall like
a virtual wall in front of you then you
would really understand like yeah I'm
just limited to the 7x7 space or
whatever but with this maybe you know
the game can limit your movement but you
can still see in the distance right so
this gives you the opportunity to be in
a part of an environment that's larger
than you can move in and if you happen
to wander too far at least you kind of
learn your limit right and watching that
video which was interesting CU you know
it's kind of cool to see you guys being
able to move like that there was that
guy kind of holding on to the cord to
kind of make sure like hey okay like the
cable rang ear right like if you had on
a camera and whatnot so how do you view
people kind of dealing with that on
their own like can they do that on their
own um I mean there were some demos that
I did uh I think different from the one
you saw where I was just sort of moving
around with the cable dangling behind me
and it does kind of feel like it can be
a bit cumbersome uh I think there are
mechanisms that could fix it say if you
have uh you know sort of a a bar with
some tension coming off your waist like
some light aluminum that just arcs it
off so it like Falls at an arc behind
you and not right down your back on your
leg to your feet that could be one
solution um you know latency is really
important with VR and that's why they're
not Wireless yet because the technology
just isn't there yeah but uh give it a
few years I'm sure companies will come
up with great Solutions if not local
Computing will become faster and then
you can just have something on your back
uh I guess the final question I have for
you on this as the person who I think
understands the most about virtual
reality in this office at least like
you've been following this for years
before any of us ever really cared um
2016 they say this is the year the
rubber is going to hit the road like
we're not talking about VR as like this
concept anymore you know the has a price
VI's going to have like pre-orders at
the end of February like people are
going to be able to buy this stuff
they're going to be able to have an
Oculus in q1 do you think enough has
happened for it to be a big success this
year not NE not next year do you think
there's enough happening this year or is
2016 going to be a transitional period
where people like us in the price get to
like play this stuff and start talking
about it are super excited but like most
Folks at home are probably just going to
be like okay I'm going to wait like you
know iPad Apple watch I'll just wait a
year or two and and and get it down the
road yeah I mean VR has been sort of
gestating now for a few years and the
way I look at it is 2016 will be the
year that it sprouts we begin to see
signs of you know where it's going to go
both uh commercially and you know as a
medium that people create things for uh
I don't think it'll be a big success in
2016 that is something that will come
probably five years down the road I I
imagine you know PlayStation VR will be
Niche uh HTC Vive will be Niche and some
of these things will you know maybe
catch more people's attention in special
locations like amusement parks things
like that you know I mean they kind of
have to start somewhere like we had
arcades back in the day we didn't have
really powerful game machines that could
handle that stuff yeah for sure give it
give it five eight years you know the
Genesis could start to you know play
some arcade ports and you know it's it's
sort of going to be that thing that that
picks up steam and before we know it it
will be that big success that is
available to all of us and a lot of the
problems that you guys are asking me
about won't really be problems at that
point so um again I think it's going to
be sprouting this year and you know it
will take probably four or five years
before it's like you know we just it's
an afterthought that we just have it and
we all love it and we all have our own
opinions about which is the best games
and not whether or not it'll be here or
not awesome thanks very much Peter
appreciate it it's q1 it's the start of
the year that's the time when not many
games come out traditionally false F
okay true tradition as somebody who is
in charge of reviewing games here games
spot that's probably not the case but
January for a while used to be pretty
quiet it was yeah but a lot of stuff got
pushed back to the Q you know to q1 2016
that's true February this year is kind
of crazy as well when I look at it gone
home conso edition's coming out H so is
that Dragon cancer which you actually
just played I just played this morning I
finished right before came into the
studio so so you're super super happy
right now it's um it's a it's a moving
game um and you know it deals with a a a
couple whose child is dying and they
have other children and they sort of
have to navigate the Waters of you know
coping with the impending tragedy coping
with explaining this to their kids who
can't actually understand what's
happening struggling with faith uh and
faith is something that you know I was
forced to go to church as a kid I never
it never really struck a chord with me
this game obviously didn't like change
my mind about that but it provided a
very interesting look into you know how
faith can affect the way people deal
with problems and how they might deal
with things when they lose faith and how
that that
absence uh is in a way both good and bad
for coping and understanding uh that's
interesting I I I felt I had like loads
of weird Catholic like growing up
Catholic emotion and very I was very
very Catholic until I was in my teens
and had quite a lot I feel like I had a
rough transition out of Catholicism H
but BioShock Infinite that really tapped
into some of that St but this game is
actually I don't want to spend too much
time on any one of these but just
because you you've literally just played
this um this is also developed by
somebody who this is like a real story
this is this actually happened to the
developer there are not many
autobiographical games out there this
one is like you can't get more
autobiographical than this they're
they're voicing it they're dealing with
their own experiences they're creating
these these abstract interpretations of
their own emotions and thought processes
and uh and yeah and and like you really
feel like you get to understand how they
feel I um the one thing I think is the
game could have been a little bit longer
uh because there are these moments where
it's so heavy and then it pulls back and
then before you know it they've sort of
like gotten over a hurdle and you feel
like man I just don't know if like I got
the the brunt of everything that they
went through that said it uh yeah like
this is a very personal story and uh it
it's got it doesn't play all that well
but play isn't important here yeah
that's not what it's about review on gam
SWOT soon yes it is uh you know it's a
special special game so we're giving the
review special attention it's written
right now now we're figuring out um how
to put the finishing touches on it and
you should see it either uh well today
or tomorrow cool tough games review yes
we had a freelancer do it game to even
decide to review like it's kind of a
that was a question do we score this
game um yeah and uh but Justin Clark our
freelancer wrote an amazing review and
um yeah I can't wait for you guys to see
it because this game needs to be talked
about people need to I think experience
it and it's one of the first games that
I was terrified to play not because it
was scary but because like I didn't want
to confront my own fears of death my own
fears of sorrow and I know I'm not the
only one it'd be very hard for me to
play I don't know if I can do it I lost
two grandparents to cancer so it's like
a it is a tough game yeah all right uh
let us know in the comments actually if
you've uh if you've uh if this is a game
you're not excited by interested in
playing or have played um is it out now
it's out now Okay cool so you can go
pick a steam I'm assuming yeah 15 bones
it's PC only uh Mac PC yeah for now yeah
so today h gone home's coming out in
console H that Dragon cancer is also out
today review going on gam spot real soon
right Pete yep awesome um January 15th
oxen free later this week uh any of
y'all interested in that uh Mary's been
playing it a bunch and she seems super
interested in it yeah I'm uh I don't
know if I'm totally interested in it
I've heard some like mixed things about
it and time is so precious right now but
uh that said a lot of people who have
played it are really enjoying it so I I
mean maybe I'll give it a shot if I have
more time it's not even supposed to be
that long like five or six hours yeah
it's the sort of thing you play over and
over again right a game that you're
probably going to want to play once
January 26 the witness finally comes out
John blow's followup to 2007's braid I
want to say it's been a while yeah 2007
or8 yes a long long time ago that's
going to be an interesting one you
interested in at all Mr T I probably not
so much I mean it looks really cool um
and you know like it's a lot of puzzles
there's like 650 or something and like
one of them's like I think J BL like oh
yeah I think 1% of you guys are going to
get this puzzle right Jesus uh that same
day Lego Marvel's Avengers is coming out
so maybe you can play that instead h two
days after that January 28th Riser the
Tomb Raider finally comes out on PC I
know people will be happy about that
February 5th then XCOM 2 that's going to
be exciting I know Andy's excited about
it uh I've played a bunch I think we can
say now uh Mike's played as well um that
game looks super cool um I'm enjoying
playing it a lot H you guys excited
about that at all XCOM 2o I didn't play
the last XCOM so I still need to play
that but I'm looking forward to another
strategy game coming out in February
what's that Fire Emblem Fates I thought
you were going to say firew watch cuz
that's coming at F February 9th the same
day when's When's Fire Emblem coming out
uh the 19th okay all right yeah uh so
February 9th fir watches out that'll be
interesting uh the mighty number n is
apparently coming out yeah we'll see
yeah it still has a list of like seven
or eight different consoles coming out
on like Vita is on there and I think 360
is on there I think we might be on there
oh [__] so we'll see I guess yeah um and
then there's a weird one so the February
9th is also the day unravel comes out
yeah but if you're on EA access you can
play that on the fourth okay that's
their typical thing right five day but
this is like a game so EA access is a
thing you can play for like 10 hours
right exactly so you can complete
basically 10 hours so you can play it on
the fourth if you want um it's one of
three access games actually to talk
about here uh one I know you're excited
about uh February 16th Street Fighter 5
is coming yeah man can't wait um
graphically looks a lot better those
like just the the gameplay feel feels a
lot better and I think this time around
hopefully crossing my fingers I same for
Peter maybe um that I I feel like that
more people will be able to play this
one at least it seems that way it feels
a little wait hold on a second are you
saying hopefully for Peter because I'm a
scrub no no I just hope that's how I
read it no no no I hope that you feel
the same way that we have more people
that want to play it you know what I
mean versus like I mean like I love that
we have people in the office that love
playing the game and but like it would
be nice to have more people and I feel
like that's what they're trying to push
a little bit with this version cuz
there's a little bit of a little bit
more simplified mechanics but also like
there's high level play which is like
finding that nice balance of you know
accessibility but you know high level
I'm looking forward to it I tried to get
into fighting games again on Street
Fighter 4 and I'm going to try again on
Street Fighter 5 um we've also got a
couple days after that on February 23rd
fir cry Primal is coming out at least on
consoles the PC version is not coming
out for a week after that crazy that is
so crazy the corner like I kind of
wouldn't be surprised if like in two
days time we find out it's been pushed
back a month or something it better be
in two days because they got to start
printing discs they got to start doing
stuff I feel like it's going to come out
though yeah it's just so close they they
wouldn't be this far along or they
wouldn't have announced it so late that
close to the release date if they
weren't confident yeah that's a fair
point um also that same day if you're
not into Far Cry Primal you can play
Plants Vs zombies Garden Warfare 2 uh
which is the second of the EA access
games which is coming out uh earlier you
can play it on February 18th um if you
so wish it's so weird cuz the thing
about unravel is you can literally play
that game and like EA access isn't like
it you can buy it earlier like you can
just go play it so like I played enough
Need for Speed on EA access I got 10
hours of that game that was enough I was
like great yep done same with
Battlefront done I literally didn't buy
Battlefront because of would you have
would you have purchase Need for Speed
if you actually wouldn't have wouldn't
have bought either of them that yeah
right but they got your subscription
bucks right so that's that's how it P
off for them I guess like it's a good
way to sort of like sweep up the people
that probably wouldn't have invested 60
bucks but 10 bucks I definitely buy on
Rival though yeah no yeah that that
looks really interesting that's a Str it
does but yeah if you want you can get
PVZ2 on February 18th on EA access um
rocket League's coming out on Xbox One
sometime in February they haven't se
said when exactly so that's TBA but on
the 1st of March finally we can play
David Cage's magnumopus Heavy Rain on
the PlayStation 4 it's coming to gen
consoles baby there you go sure yep
French sounding children now on the
PlayStation 4 all right that's enough
talk about that uh March 8th Tom Clan's
the division is coming out that's crazy
that's like less than two months away a
couple months ago we were saying where
is the division now it's knock knock
knock we'll see we'll see about that uh
we can't really talk more about that at
all at the moment so hopefully we will
be able to soon um March 11th hitman's
coming out that was a game that was
really originally going to come out
December with that first package that
really weird release plan where it's
like you're paying full price but you're
getting all the stuff but just yeah yeah
you'll get it later it's like yeah I've
yet to see that work anywhere people
were even frustrated with Mario Maker
when it was giving you things slight
like hours later so the idea of weeks
later for Content seems a bit crazy at
least for full price game you know it's
the it's the sort of thing that I mean I
actually am not a big Hitman fan anyway
or any kind of Hitman fan that's sort of
thing that just makes me feel really
comfortable not caring about that oh
really it's like on a personal level not
caring about it yeah um uh the last game
I guess well actually the last game
that's coming out that month is at the
end is UF the new UFC is coming out I
got Conor McGregor shirt on the only
champion on the box razy lers let's hope
there's no
curse no EA curse please that's that's
the third of the EA access ones but more
importantly I think for for The Wider
gaming World March 28th uh is when a
drift Kronos eval
come out because it's the same day that
the Oculus Rift comes out Kronos is
awesome I think once more people get a
chance to play that they'll realize how
how cool it is it's like the one it's
one of the few games that I think takes
traditional game design and ports it
well to VR by tweaking a few things it
is sort of the atmosphere and puzzles of
Zelda with the the tone is similar to
Atmosphere but the tone and gameplay of
Dark Souls uh it's it's great it's real
fun really liked it you got me to play
it at Gamescom yeah and I was really
taken back by how much I enjoyed it
actually that's good cool yeah GL GL not
alone Oculus Rift as well if you
pre-ordered you can get one you'll be
getting one on 28th hopefully I know
they they they push back the dates for
some people um and then the last thing I
gave this its own section because
there's too many of them I'm not sure if
anyone gives a [__] so if you don't care
about Assassin's Creed Chronicles you
can just stop watching this video right
now but if you do care um the last two
Assassin's Creed Chronicles games I
guess China came out last year if feel
it came out a while ago like it feels
like it came out maybe back in September
of October I I probably should have
researched that it's been a while anyway
India Assassin's Creed Chronicles India
coming out January 12th then Assassin's
Creed Chronicles Russia is coming out
February 9th and that's also the same
day that the trilogy which will'll have
China India and Russia all together uh
is coming out as well so if you want to
play some hot 2D Assassin's Creed video
game they got your back UB stof got
three games uh for you to play uh okay
that's that's all the games coming out
q1 2016 if you had to pick a favorite
out of all of those what would it be
take first um out of all that probably
Street Fighter 5 with some hope that the
division is kind of fun cuz something
Destiny like but not Destiny right now
I'm feeling real weird on the division
I'm feeling I can't get into it but I
feel like it's either going to be it's
either going to be another Watchdog
disappointment or it's going to be
something [__] cool and I really
can't tell right now it's like I'm can't
wait to see more about that uh I'm
probably more excited about XCOM 2 than
everything else the witness as well I'm
actually super excited about um and
maybe Far Cry Primal what about yourself
uh Fire Emblem Fates and with the dash
Street Fighter 5 cool awesome H let us
know what you are most excited about uh
in the comment box below what are you
looking forward to in Q3 what do you
think will slip and what do you think
will suck let us know in the comments
all right folks uh we've had a a nice
bit of chatter about video games but
it's time to let the game creators
talk for themselves folks yeah I know
they've got a voice huh they want to
talk about the games they made and
sometimes they want to play games that
they actually didn't make it all and
that's what we have this week so you
guys asked for more developer stuff uh
on the lobby last week Steve Gainer the
Creator uh or one of the many creators
at the full bright company uh those who
made gone home was in town gone home is
coming out today on Xbox One on
PlayStation 4 so we got him in to talk
about gone home I what better way to
talk about gone home than playing the
gone home map in Counter Strike so this
is a video of me and Steve talking about
games without guns that are in first
person while playing gone home in
Counter
Strike enjoy hello folks and welcome to
a very special episode of we play
developers games in Counterstrike Steve
Gainer you created a wonderful video
game which not many people played but it
did go on to create the biggest
Counter-Strike map in the history of Cs
I I I like to think of it as our Legacy
you can obviously play this on uh PC you
can played on Console as of Tuesday yeah
gone home uh is out this week on Xbox
one and PlayStation 4 the thing is like
that I really appreciate about this is I
feel like just from playing it that it's
a real kind of labor of love you know
it's it's like effort's been put in yeah
it's an it's it feels like an homage or
you know just like really trying to yeah
like right here on my screen um you'll
remember in gone home there's this light
and there's this little crucifix next to
it and he just used level geometry to
put this little crucifix oh yeah look at
on uh that's awesome yeah so you know
those those kind of things go a long way
so check so is this going to be in here
let's find out that secret isn't in
there but I can probably just Rob this
to do it let's see yeah there we go
secret passage get down there get down
there get down there get God I keep
walking into this room with this wood
just full of [__] it's like this is
the worst made CS map ever just like
dead ends everywhere it's almost like
it's almost like it was never intended
for anyone to play an FPS in this level
what is this so have people stopped
giving you [__] about it being a walking
simulator no no just more people are
making walking simulators so it's fine
now you Trend Setter firewatch and the
witness uh you know are coming out in
the next couple months we had uh maybe
it's like Soma feel probably Amnesia was
an influence on us you know it's a it's
it's a horror game but it's a non-combat
horror game your only abilities are you
know walk around hide find lamp oil you
know and and that's and that's cool like
Amnesia was one of the games that showed
us like oh oh yeah you know they're
doing something unique with a non-combat
first-person experience um dear Ester
did something unique with combat first
person experience 30 Flights of Loving
um there are all of these reference
points and I think you know those games
and Stanley Parable and you know uh
other stuff that that has come out in
the interam I think has kind of
popularize the idea of there's a lot we
can do here you know like we're we're
working on Tacoma for our next game
there's um a drift that's coming out
which is like a a floating simulator you
know what I mean but I I think that um
walking I think it's one of those terms
where walking simulator kind of started
as like a burn and then it's like well
it's actually just I don't know it's
what we got like that's the best name
for it you walk around and stuff happens
is cool I don't know and it's now an
established genre with actually a bunch
of quite good games in it yeah what's
the fastest you've ever completed gone
home in uh 49
seconds die die die die die yes I got a
kill yeah so if that's if the through
line is that there's no guns like
especially somebody who's worked on
Bioshock which are you know Wonderful
narrative games which some people
especially infinite have said that kind
of were maybe are they hamstrung by the
fact that they need to have shooting in
them well or you know people are at
least like oh the best you know the best
part of infinite was when you weren't
shooting the first hour or so yeah um I
I think that kind of on the opposite
side of it you know I I was the lead and
writer of manura den which was the DLC
for BioShock 2 fantastic DLC as well I
mean we were yeah we really proud of it
and in a in a lot of ways um oh my God I
just noticed sorry in the top corner
there's the mini map and and you made it
the a map screen from gone home that's I
had noticed that you play through the
whole game you get through the all the
way through the power curve of a
BioShock game you beat the boss of
manura den and then the last you know 10
15 minutes 10 minutes of the game are
you go down into Porter's office and
your your guns go down and it's just
about you being an En enironment
listening to an audio diary exploring
this evidence of what was in this guy's
personal space and what it meant to him
and so you know we were kind of I think
starting to explore the idea of what's
Bioshock without guns as kind of the um
damal of a Bioshock experience in that
case um and you know in infinite it was
like the introduction to a Bioshock
experience and I think that that's
something that um I really need to buy
guns I keep getting I just keep I just
keep coming out with my shitty Glock and
I'm like why do I keep dying oh right
cuz other guys have like assault rifles
well we're also doing an interview and
we can't hear gameplay either I think
those are bad excuses for us being bad
at games yeah that'll be the headline
gone home Creator sucks at real games
and that's part of of what we were going
for was saying like we want to see what
it's like to to have you know a game
where the the heart of the experience is
the non-combat story exploration and
that it is intentionally like a small
focused
single you know um um Arc where it's
like okay I I played through this in a
few hours and I could really delve into
it and now I feel like some closure you
know like I actually I I I started this
thing and I played it over the course of
one you know long you know evening of
gameplay or a couple of days and I
really felt like I got to like fully uh
uh internalize all of that and and feel
like I had a complete experience yeah
does the limit from that come from the
fact that it's it's difficult to hold
people's attention if they're not
engaging in that sort of of combat or
does the limit in that come from that's
just the best type of narrative
experience you can make is that it is
dense and that it does sort of wrap up
before it overstays it time I think it's
a few different things in our case so by
the way kitchen good pizza box in the
place where there's a pizza box in the
game good refrigerator so I think for us
it was both because we needed to build a
small game cuz we were a small team and
we're doing it on our own um resources
which are you know limited um but uh you
know I I think think there is some real
value to having uh uh the length of a
story especially like a you know small
personal story be um Jesus this a
grenade party Happening Here uh be be
like focused and not overstay as welome
I think we don't know if we could make
this be good for that long 12 hours if
we wanted to so it's kind of good that
we can't cuz you like we're we're just
going to do the best we can with making
a few hours long and and having the
density of the The Experience so you
feel like every room is really filled
with a lot of stuff that's worth seeing
you know you don't feel like well here's
Just Another Empty room here's one thing
with like one you know one note in it um
it's going to be interesting to see what
the witness ends up doing then because
that might be a question that that
answers yeah I I think I feel like the
witness is you know a lot of land mass a
lot of um kind of ambient exploration
but I think that that's you know that's
partly what the the puzzle aspect is is
about you know um I it'll be really
interesting to to see yeah what what
that really means I think in practice oh
[__] no I'm getting shot by enemy
mans unlucky so does this ever make you
think oh we should have made like a
competitive gone home experience yes or
like a or like a CO off [__] I just shot
my friend that was me no no I'm shooting
all my friends I hate my friends why why
why why why do I act like this I'm going
to go that could be your parents coming
back oh no that was oh this was why the
house was empty because the teys killed
everyone before you got here there's
someone
here oh [__] I need to hide can we can
we hide under the stairs [__] this guy
[__] this guy no you got him no I didn't
Mr V oh he's I can tell you where he is
cuz we're oh so we you're saying we can
cheat yeah stay there stay I'll tell you
when he's going to come in the corner
okay we're cheating yeah just stay there
we cheating he's he's like 5T out okay
he's going to be there in three
two oh final round okay it says final
round does yeah yeah yeah this is going
to be final round so do we're 7v7 oh
[__] you're in the Attic oh they stuck
me
downstairs oh no there's a dead person
there already [__] you Mr V I'm going to
avenge you yes I killed him oh
nice oh [__] some garbage com he killed
garbage com [__] oh
home don't don't kill Steve Steve made
the game this is based on be nice to him
him is me Steve is GS man no no right
spray spray and prey I got I got season
greeting instead know it sucks doesn't
it oh what's going to happen this is
tight this is like this is close yeah
7v7 God oh there's two of there's two
there's two of them and one of us up in
the attic how fitting that the Game
ending yeah in the Attic an epic
showdown in the Attic take
oh congratulations counterterrorist
congratulations Mr V no Ray Frank at 67
congratulations gone home Counterstrike
Community yeah congratulations C gone
home in this incredibly popular
competitive
[Music]
map gang spots Game of the Year 2015 was
The Witcher 3 wild Hunt that's kind of
all yall got to hear was that that was
the game of the year what you didn't get
to hear was all of the screaming and
conversations and throwing a feces all
of that stuff uh so we're going to get
into a little bit of that sort of we got
got into that or how we got around to
the widger 3 and this but also this is
kind of more importantly what I want to
do is like this is Andy had this idea
we're going to round up everyone else's
Game of the Year Awards so we're going
to basically cast shade on all the other
games websites and say that's [__]
that's [__] or what we agree um
let's get into our conversation I guess
via some of the other winners so Games
Radar picked meter Solid 5 the fan of
pay inest game of the year it was that
rocket league and The Witcher was kind
of this like three-way conversation that
we had forever H Peter that was your
favorite Game of the Year you gave it 10
out of 10 um on gang spot this year was
fantastic for games we a couple 10 out
of 10 that was one of them um yeah what
did you what did you think about the
conversation we had about like you agree
with Games Radar that it was Game of the
Year what do you think about the
conversations that we had about Witcher
and Rocket league and all that stuff I
haven't read games Radar's justification
uh I think it's a phenomenal game and uh
you know one of the things whenever I
talk about before I start talking about
why I love it I always have to preface
like cut cut people off by saying I know
there's problems like right I know there
are times when quiet is just unnecessary
like her appearance I know the second
half of the game had some pacing issues
and the story maybe felt truncated at
Parts um but for me you know the first
thing was the game play was just
impeccable like there's so many things
happening at once and once you really
get in tune with the controls it it all
happens so seamlessly and you almost
forget how intricate it was to begin
with but then when you look back or you
start to play other games you're like
why aren't I transitioning from one
position to another as smoothly like how
come I can't just quickly whip something
out or react to a a scenario um so the
game the the controls were one aspect
the visual presentation both within
cinematics and within the game was
astounding and and that made it really
easy for me to just sort of find myself
you know in awe of what was happening
around me um and and quiet you know
again for as many problems as she has uh
I don't want to spoil anything for
anyone who hasn't played unless you guys
age no no don't don't don't spoil it
don't spoil it but get to like yeah I
know yeah she you're allowed to take
companions with you into the field and
uh I used her quite a bit because I
liked her abilities I thought they gave
me a good tactical Advantage
right and uh she can't speak for one
reason or another and uh but one thing
she can do is hum and so you know you
don't always see her when she's with you
versus like d dog who's next to you
right she could be off somewhere but you
have radio communication and when she's
trying to tell you that she's ready to
do something she starts to hum this
little tune in her ear and I never like
it's easy to feel alone in Metal Gear
even if you've got you know your dog
with you cuz it's an animal that's
really not that smart like you can kind
of tell what to do and it's cute but
it's really you can only rely on
yourself and big Bo is basically a one
man army yeah like but not with quiet
with quiet you're a two-man Army and you
know I I I I felt really attached to her
and the way that the game sort of
manipulated that feeling of attachment
right it it I can't remember a game that
I've ever played that made me wrestle
with so many feelings you know for for
one character like that um and that like
but it wasn't even like a scripted part
of the story I mean it right it's
scripted but optional the sort of things
that happen and it all has to do
with how attached to her you are yes how
much yeah you're let's not get into it
anymore but that that was kind of what
like the Crux of the last the the
biggest the most frustrating part of the
game of year conversation was between
these kind of three games and where they
sat and how it worked because like that
experience that you had I didn't have
because not alone did I not use her very
often I also only completed the first
half of that game which was like 70
hours whatever but like I didn't so I
didn't even get to past that point you
hadn't completed The Witcher three right
so all the things we were talking about
was and like these were both games that
were like 120 hours long we had played
all these other games and then like
rocket league is this trying to compare
rocket league with meal Gad to The
Witcher is a [__] nightmare because
it's like it's a five minute game and it
repeats it just for some people it
really works it worked for rock paper
shotgun they they gave it there they did
loads of weird Game of the Year kind of
bits and Bobs all over place they said
it was their favorite overall game of
the year and yeah you you cited on that
one right you you still think it was the
best game that came out last year yeah
and I [__] love Metal Gear Sol like I
played a lot of it on PC and you love
The Witcher oh I love love The Witcher
if I'm we're going to give like love
love love and Love Love Rocket League
it's our new rating system on gam spot
uh but yeah so like midle gear was
awesome and there's so many systems that
play and everybody just goes on and on
about that and it's true did you finish
it I did not finish it damn it but like
I got so many things there's so I know I
know but like more than even what I was
talking about earlier and we had the
same problem in the setting in here
especially like that kind of 80s but
Tech like higher Tech than we have now
but like cold war and Soviets Man play
play that game post World well
so yeah and like it's so strong the the
movement and the stealth and all the
abilities like you're saying don't get
me wrong like that was a phenomenal
achievement and then you go to like
Witcher right and I'm such a huge
Witcher fan Fanboy and like that game
delivered on every little thing you
would ever want out of open world
Witcher game it's all so subjective
though isn't it like it's all
anticipation and what you want and
Rocket league is like a game you don't
even know anything about exactly and but
like the characters and everything in
The Witcher like that's basically all
the Witcher can stand on I think because
like the game play is all right and the
systems are kind of Jank and the
inventory is Jank and the crafting
whatever it's it's deep but like do you
really want to hang your hat on it yeah
it has more wrinkles than me gear for oh
yeah for sure um but like it's so strong
like as a narrative experience and like
as a game fan and as like artist you
know whatever like we love like I love
that [__] like that's when I think about
Game of the Year it's like aspiring to
Greatness right what game got there the
best that's kind of way so what is it
rocket league so so this transitions
into that right so it's like I think
middle gear was like systems the best
game Witcher was like art yeah the best
game but then it's like okay and then
out of nowhere rocket League consumed my
[__] life like fun it's it became a
sport it's intoxicating and yeah and I
think the reason that I have to say it's
my personal Game of the Year why I think
we should have pushed it for game of the
year was it's going to stand longer in
my life than either of those games uh
not just like playtime wise but just
length of time wise and when you think
back of like the games you loved in like
10 years from now you'll click that one
out yeah like when when I have to rank
my personal games of all time rocket
leagues on that list whereas like metal
gear kind of falls down and so does
Witcher because like I because like IR
it's irrational love of games like it's
Skyrim max pain but but funny thing
about that is that like what that's the
problem we had because by the time we
got to those last three it's so personal
it's like and like and how do you say my
personal feeling of this game is more
than you because I guess the problem we
had was that you definitely loved mear
solid perhaps more than the median level
but there was this Force for Rocket
League because there was so many people
so we just had to like we had to talk
between like the conversations were long
because was like how went does you know
popular vote matter against consensus
vote right well so that was the thing
though is that we ran like a staff-wide
popular vote and the numbers were very
different for the top three like metal
gear had way more support and until we
started to to whittle things down and
and you know have these open discussions
and an impassioned speech can change
people change people's mind and passion
one way or another can really alter
people's opinions I think it's easy to
argue logically for rocket league as
well like as like all the games you can
argue logically but like as a video game
like it's it is a [__] video game
like you're playing it you're
interacting you're getting better you're
you're playing with your team it's like
it's the culmination of all this modern
stuff like good matchmaking like it was
free so everybody there's a huge pool of
players like you get better and good
online Communication online
communication like easy communication
like Journey style right problem no
problem to take the shot defend it like
it's you you know you just it just
becomes and this stupid thing I wrote
that I I'm going to share and it's so
far up my own butt but who cares it was
like so Witcher it's a dark place so
this is just comparing Witcher and AR
Witcher the the art is the writing the
characterization the acting the
storytelling uh the pacing everything
that goes into that but like the The
Poetry in rocket league is actually you
doing it on the field like you leave
your mark on the field baby you're
talking about the beautiful game and to
me that's more powerful a in a way right
yeah like but okay but so why is that
why is that different from something
like FIFA and I'm not saying that I
think it it isn't good question but I
just but that I think people would
probably benefit from hearing why Danny
actually like broke that down really
well where it's second fif you're
playing as a team the the the quick
elevator pitch of that is like in FIFA
you're playing as a team and in rocket
League you're playing as a foot you're
like your your direction over the ball
is is it's like it's about where you hit
that ball and where it goes not the
plays you're making so it's kind of like
it's like like a macro micro kind of
thing and for me like rocket League uh
I've said it a bunch of times last year
was like it was the best soccer game
best football game I've ever played
because it felt more like when I was
like I played football my whole life and
it felt more like when even like the
weirdest thing is like cuz I played on
goal like from my whole life like at
various like levels like i' I've played
for like 20 years I guess and I have had
times where I have like as a goalkeeper
predominantly so I've had times where
I've run across the goal and like finger
tipped like anticipated this ball I
think it's going to go there if they hit
it and I've barely saved it and I still
remember those moments and like I have
done that in rocket league and it's felt
the same sure so and that's like really
strange so powerful but anyway so that's
that kind of stuff that we got into so
it's interesting to look at some of the
other winners on different websites the
guardian gave for instance bloodborne
was one that bloodborn fans like the
people who want bloodborne to be game of
the year are so sure that it's game of
the year and we had a lot of people
saying like it's fine you think that
bloodborn is the best game that came out
this year or Ps or sorry um The Guardian
thought that as well what do you think
about that pet it's TI game yeah know
it's a it's one of those games that I
wish I was better at because I didn't
get I wasn't able to finish it um and
partially that was due to time because I
wasn't able to get better but that game
has amazing atmosphere and it has really
really good mechanics that are difficult
but fair um I think it has a lot of
going things going for it what I think
what's missing from me when when
listening to other people talk about it
is that it was solid but not special
right and uh I'm not sure why maybe
that's because we have dark souls and
that was sort of a semi blueprint for uh
for bloodborne um but at the same time
like I'm not going to sit here and say
it's not an amazing game that doesn't
deserve recognition and if they had the
best experience with it then kudos to
them like that's that's what they
believe it is a little bit of an outlier
in terms of the median that should not
be uh denied that's not like this is the
interesting thing about Game of the ears
is that like nobody's wrong uh which is
uh IGN for instance the Imagine games
Network they pick the same game we did
which were three wild Hunt um I I guess
the one this is the one we're leading up
to because it's it's the one in which
people are saying like no that's wrong
and I think there's a lot of interesting
discussion to have about this which is
that although polygon gave Witcher the
best open world game their game of the
year eventually went to her story which
is a game I think we had on I think it
was like 18th or so on ours so we did
recognize it as a as a great game but it
won a bunch of awards at the game awards
it's kind of in a lot of people's top 10
around there um but it is kind of
interesting to think that
either the consensus Vote or the popular
vote put a game that was so far down the
list of so many people's uh game of the
year uh right at the top uh Peter what
do you think about
that it kind of does speak to the people
who work at polygon right it does like
it makes sense it's like oh okay yeah of
course that's the game the polygon will
probably go for right um yeah but I
don't know that I want to like Whittle
it down to just the identity of polygon
or just sort of like well we know who
works there and what they like right but
you know like people we so concentrated
in our discussions because we work in an
office together like the games that we
play like rocket League that we fall in
love with you know that sort of it
starts to fold in on itself and become
you know this deeper thing uh and so who
knows maybe the right mix of people
played it there and and gotten enough
people's ears and then they played it
and their discussions around it were
more impassion because in the office
here you know when we started playing
that game it was like oh her story is
actually pretty interesting you know
like and then we we kind of like dabbled
in talking about certain things but I
also don't think enough people played it
and I don't think we had long enough
discussions about what happened in that
game uh and why it worked and I think
maybe if we did and this probably
applies to other games as well it may
have been higher on our list probably
wouldn't have been top 10 though right
uh or at least number one no I I don't
think I don't think so not based on the
personalities we have here and again I
hate to sort of just like put people
into a corner at polygon or any website
and say well of course they chose that
but um but you know I mean there is this
perception that they are very socially
focused and uh they're into experimental
stuff and you know whatever that's
that's kind of an interesting thing
actually that we kind of touched on um a
lot of times in our conversations here
is that like games press loves something
new like we probably appreciate the new
more than most uh like the median gamer
because we're interacting with so many
games all the time so when there's
something new it kind of like Sparks a
joy in us because we're used to playing
so many so many things so I wonder if
there's something because the public
reaction to something like this is
either people saying like oh okay that's
great you're championing a new type a
different type of game then the other
people would say like oh it's an FMV
game and you're just being contrarian
for the sake of it because like you want
to look different and no one's going to
pick her story this year uh so if what
we're talking about is actually that
this is just something that they really
liked uh is it to be criticized or like
how do you feel about the idea that the
games press should represent Gamers and
not tell it should or like where does it
represent Gamers and where does it
represent people writing you know what I
mean cuz that's I feel like that's how
people look at our game of the year as
well they go like pick the right one
because you're speaking for us you know
what I mean anyone at home who thinks
that that should be the case next time
you're talking to your friends about
games talk about the games that you
think your sister would like I mean
that's a ridiculous notion like why
should I why should I have to change who
I am like if I'm in this position and my
position is to talk about the games that
I care about the way I want to know or
the way that I want to talk about them
that's my prerogative that's all I care
about games are very personal they're
not this thing that is to be like mixed
together and then like slopped on a
plate and say here you go that this is
games for every Peter can I have some
more no yeah it's
uh I mean this this is the problem we
face in comment sections right where
people people get very personal but they
don't realize because they think we're
doing a disservice because they think
that's what the average person wants and
the there is no average person unless
unless you're trying to go for like
which game sells the most but that comes
down to so many different hey guess what
how many people had Call of Duty on like
if you want like the next layer
exactly the next layer of that is like
cuz we can't say oh like then if if
polygon are like let's just say they're
being on like the you know they're
representing 1% of and like we're
representing more people because we
picked the like [__] man like Destiny
right like the taken King didn't qualify
but that that's what people were playing
people were playing DOTA in League of
Legends Call of Duty that's a good
question that I want to like pause it
right yeah go for it what if cuz we do
the game of the year and cuz we cuz it's
fun I guess and gets traffic whatever
but like I really enjoy the process I
think it's like super fun it's a good
way to like actually talk about games I
kind of wish didn't have as much impor
attached to it that's the only thing I
don't like but like what if we had a
every year there was an adjustment to
like the best game ever right oh so it's
like it's like a top 100 list that we
just change 100 seems like a so Half
Life 2 still at the top so yeah it's
like five like one of the five best
games ever and it's like every year you
like reevaluate it and it's like Counter
Strike is still number one yeah like
half life and it's like so how do you be
better than that like dota's up there
right like and then what else I don't
know Peter's like shaking his head like
that that's just that doesn't that's
like that's this year's problem multiply
by 100 exactly if I had my way we would
all write reviews without scores and
just leave it at that we wouldn't do
these top 10 lists we wouldn't do oh
yeah it you know I think it I think it
can devalue like the the conversations
around games really easily and ranking
games it just becomes like a crap not a
crap shoot but it becomes a a very
difficult process to actually be sound
and reasonable be able to easily
quantify this is better than that yeah
at a certain stage you just stand cuz we
are like hypocritical by Nature so it's
like we're going to change our minds and
contradict and it's like so subjective
and it's so [__] out there people are
playing loads of Counter-Strike right
now they weren't maybe 10 years ago me
that gone home map is just blowing up
you know and so it's like what what made
that happen like League of Legends is
super popular but like I can't play it
you know what I mean it's crazy it seem
like last year felt like a year where it
was so difficult like any one of these
games you could say is like easily like
somebody's and not even just somebody's
like one person's but lots of people's
favorite g game of the year bloodborne
Witcher her story rocket League met
soles like it's not hard for me to say
oh this is my number one anything benath
that it's like [__] I don't between five
and six like yeah if I move them does
that look right like did I like City
skylines more than Mario maker
like do you wish there was like an
academy you had more time to your life
so that you didn't have well that's the
problem okay yeah so final point on this
I guess is like okay the end game of
this is that we end up having something
like the Oscars right it's like we don't
look at the game awards as like that's
the be all and end all uh and different
various people look towards different
people like some people look towards
like okay I want to know what like total
Biscuit's favorite game of the year is
or I want to know what games spots is or
I want to know what like my favorite
twitch streamer is what like different
people have different layers of import I
don't think think we want some like one
Bastion of that cuz the the Oscars feel
like they get it wrong every year or
like or or they try and go for that
popular vote or somewhere between the
popular vote and the Artic artistic vote
and they kind of like Birdman is the her
story of films right well yeah Birdman
is like a bman is a game made for film
critics and you could say her story is a
game that probably appeals to game
critics more than it does to you know
Joe Call of Duty if that's the median
gamer so like I don't know I just want
to recognize things for the special
achievement
like I I fire me gam spot you know but
like I just I just think it's it's what
we're doing you know it doesn't really
serve a really strong discussion about
games it just distracts and and makes us
argue again we try to say this is the
best the worst whatever we should just
have like Peter Brown game of the year
and that's it we don't say anybody
else's like we choose one person every
year and that's their year like [__]
Hunger Games yeah we have like we have
like a [__] Gauntlet you have to go
no no no yeah yeah we we volunteer Peter
as tribute and then we get all the other
I mean we basically a packs yeah yeah we
get all the other games press to pick
and then who wins that gets game we
figured it out we fig out did it we
cracked this baby Andy Peter thanks so
much for coming on here and figuring out
game of the year 2016 you with me
appreciate it h let us know what you
think was Game of the Year 2015 uh which
publication you cited with also let us
know like what do you think of the idea
that anyone can pick any game for Game
of the Year do you think there's
importance assigned a game of the year
do you have an appreciation for the fact
that this stuff is so subjective and you
know ultimately you shouldn't really
push your opinion against someone else's
opinion or is that something you enjoy
let us know in the comments below all
right we're done for a show this week
thanks so much Peter Brown for coming in
yeah you're a busy boy especially with
cs so really appreciate you coming in
love being here this week Andy bman
pleasure as ever Eric Tay who's
currently behind the camera really
appreciate it h we're all building the
new show at the moment um Josh Shaw
isn't here at the moment because he uh
we're not using the tricaster fingers
cross next week we'll be doing this live
and maybe we'll have some of that we'll
see uh let us know what you think of the
show but we're also going to do on the
way out of here we didn't want to talk
about it too too much because it's it
feels a little bit strange uh David boy
passed two days ago obviously he had a
big influence on a lot of media he had a
big influence on games as well you look
at like look at the culture of of games
in 2015 even with like Metal Gear Solid
having so many references to Bo's work
throughout it um Amicon the NAD so of
course Quantic dreams first game back in
1999 he was involved in he MOA and he
also did some design elements of it uh
so we want to do a little bit of a shout
out to D Bo and also uh Josh's snake c
not the Cy Sark Cy Sark also died that
same day so we're going to do an Ode to
both Bowie and that beautiful snake rest
in peace David boy rest in peace Cody
Sark see you next
[Music]
week
the